[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm Jessica.
And today, I'm going to
talk about her reaction I
like to call Midas' Magic.
And before I get started, let's
watch the reaction in action
with the help of Dr.
Bassam Shakashiri.
And here he is.
He's actually the president of
the American Chemical Society.
And his motto is,
"Science is fun."
Here he is at MIT.
And let's see what
he has to show us.
BASSAM SHAKASHIRI: Watch this.
Here i take this clear
and colorless liquid.
And I put some of it in the
beaker, about 100 milliliters.
How do I know it's
about 100 milliliters?
AUDIENCE: It says so.
BASSAM SHAKASHIRI: I'm
reading the markers on here,
on the beaker.
And I take about 100
millimeters of a different
clear and colorless liquid.
But you don't know
that it's different.
They look the same, right?
And look at this.
Look what's going to happen now.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
AUDIENCE: It's yellow.
BASSAM SHAKASHIRI:
Isn't that one
of the most fascinating
observations you make?
You take two clear,
colorless liquids.
You mix them together, and
you get a yellow substance
that is insoluble in water.
This is lead iodide.
I mixed potassium
iodide solution
with lead nitrate solution.
So the magician never tells
you how the trick works.
But in science, we like
to know what's going on.
JESSICA HARROP: So
what is going on?
Let's break it down.
Dr. Shakashiri started with
two clear, colorless liquids.
He had about 100
milliliters of lead nitrate.
And that's aqueous.
That's in solution.
And about 100 milliliters
of potassium iodide, also
aqueous, and when he
mixed those together,
he got a yellow precipitate.
Let's color that in yellow.
A precipitate is a solid.
So how do we know what
this yellow solid is?
Well, this is the
reaction that's
called a double
displacement reaction.
And in this kind of reaction,
the cation and anion pairs
switch places.
So what exactly does that mean?
I'm going to use some
colors to help me out.
So we've got cations and anions
in each of these compounds.
The cations have
positive charge.
So in this case, it's
lead, which has a 2+ charge
and nitrate, NO3-.
You need two of those to
have a neutral compound.
Our other compound, over here,
has potassium, which has a +1.
And our anion is
iodide, which is -1.
When these two solutions
are mixed, we've got lead,
which is our +2.
And it's going to
react with iodide.
We need two of them to
make it a neutral compound.
And potassium nitrate, and we
just need one nitrate here.
So our cations and anions
all switched places.
We're going to need to balance
this equation let's throw
some twos there and there.
So how can we predict which
one of these two compounds
is the yellow precipitate?
Hundreds of years ago,
chemists mixed ions together.
And they came up with solubility
tables, just like this one.
Now this chart
basically shows us
when these two ions, an ion
from this column and this column
are mixed together,
is their product,
a compound that they form,
soluble or insoluble in water?
If it's soluble
in water, there's
an aq for aqueous on the chart.
And if it's insoluble in
water, there's an s for solid.
So our two compounds that we
want to look at our lead iodide
and potassium nitrate.
So let's take a look.
Potassium nitrate--
we've got potassium
down here at the bottom.
We've got nitrate
here at the top.
When mixed together, aqueous
solution, soluble in water.
So it's more likely that
our lead iodide would
be the yellow precipitate.
But let's see if that's true.
Lead mixed with iodide--
voila.
It's a solid.
So to recap,
solubility tables help
chemists predict whether or
not a precipitate will form
when two solutions are mixed.
So going back to our equation
here, the lead iodide--
this is the yellow precipitate.
It's a solid.
And the potassium
nitrate is aqueous.
And even though I
didn't paint my nails
with this particular
pigment, lead iodide,
creating nail
polish colors is one
of the many different
things that chemists can do.
So there we go.
I hope you enjoyed Midas' Magic.
And I will see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]